take a look at this picture this is
James Bond he's the typical archetype of
the hero he's smooth strong assertive
handsome never makes mistakes he's just
perfect now look at this picture this is
Charles Bukowski he's the typical
archetype of the anti-hero he was
rebellious he was ugly he was a rascal
but he possessed an extraordinary skill
he was an exceptional writer at least
for some people myself in included
Bukowski was born in an age when the
idea of the American dream was a rich
Zenith everyone wanted to have the
perfect job the perfect house the
perfect wife the perfect husband some
did achieve it some didn't the ones who
did realized soon enough that the
American dream was a fad a story
invented by marketers to sell a healthy
version of capitalism that could
maintain the idea of consumerism and
keep the machine running the moment they
got what they so immensely desired
reality hit them hard and they
understood that the American dream
wasn't as lucrative as it seemed the
ones who didn't were just looking at the
ones who did with jealousy and with an
astute lack of awareness of what was
happening behind the scenes Bukowski
belonged to the second category his
parents were German immigrants and he
was raised in a poor and abusive
environment growing up his chances of
success and the potential suit of the
American dream were minuscule he found
himself working minial jobs while trying
to make ANS meet and eventually he
settled a job in a post office writing
was for him an escape and a way to
relieve his mental pain the pain
transformed into depression and this
depression bolstered his rage as he grew
older and gave him much of his voice and
material for his writings Bukowski
didn't receive any praise for his great
ability to present reality in such a r
and poetic way until his early 50s when
his writings became known though he
amased a following so devoted and
ecstatic with his work that even the
most vigorous proponents of the American
dream would envy mkasi wasn't by any
means the perfect person even during his
most successful days he didn't feel that
his life was perfect life was for him a
perennial absurdity that included
instances of perfection like women booze
riding and public orations for his fans
though he was an idol he represented
ideas that deeply resonated with their
soul and allowed them to picture reality
through an unconventional and
anti-heroic lens for them this was a big
deal for them he was
perfect human nature can be summarized
as the Eternal effort to transcend the
limits of our abilities in an attempt to
escape everything wrong with The Human
Condition since since the dawn of human
consciousness and the realization of the
fact that we are aware of our own
existence we have been trying to create
stories that allow us to make this
existence more meaningful the idea that
there is no meaning and that we just are
was quite unappetizing so the people who
were able to create the more beguiling
and convincing stories were the ones
whose stories dominated the world the
stories usually included various
inaccuracies and metaphysical
explanations of obscure phenomena but
their theme was quite similar there is a
Divine or heroic entity that created the
world as we can experience it and this
entity is regarded as the manifestation
of the ideal human this entity is
omnipresent omniscient and omnipotent in
simple words it is perfect the moment we
believe in stories about Divine and
heroic entities that represent the ideal
version of us and in a way what all of
us ought to become we all prey to
perfectionism the consequences of such a
situation are innumerable living a life
while holding the conviction that
whatever you do should aim for
Perfection is stressful and honorous to
say the least especially if you don't
really know whether you will ever reach
that perfect State especially if you
never really know if your attempts will
ever be appreciated Let's us face it
we're all victims of perfectionism when
you enter the self-development sphere
you do so in a very enthusiastic itic
and often times irresponsible fashion
you get star struck by the lashious
titles and The Superficial realities and
you forget to take a step back look at
the bigger picture and properly evaluate
what is good for you what is interesting
what is actionable what is snake oil and
what is plain nonsense the virus of
perfectionism digs its way into your
core and instead of becoming the vessel
that will Propel you towards Divinity it
evolves into an ill-informed version of
a religion today I see perfectionism the
way it is described by various
self-development Outlets as
superficiality they present a version of
reality so distant and so cheesy that
essentially degrades the true essence of
growth and eventually alienates the
audience a person who gets coaxed into
the craze of perfectionism will suffer
the inevitable consequences associated
with the lack of attaining it
consequences like fear of missing out
self-blame lack of motivation and
Detachment from reality to name but a
few if anything I feel that
re-engineering the idea of perfectionism
constitutes a great challenge that one
has to follow with caution nonetheless I
will attempt to propose some ideas that
can act as a starting point for
assuaging the pain associated with
perfectionism and its
byproducts Freud in his Monumental work
civilization and its discontent attempts
to identify the most effective
techniques for alleviating human
suffering one of them is sublimation for
which he States the following another
technique for avoiding suffering makes
use of the displacements of the libido
that are permitted by our physical
apparatus and lend its functioning so
much flexibility here the task is to
displace the aims of the drives in such
a way that they cannot be frustrated by
the external world sublimation of the
drives plays a part in this we achieve
most if we can sufficiently heighten the
pleasure derived from mental and
intellectual work fate can then do
little to harm us Freud's way of writing
has always fascinated me despite the
numerous objections his theories have
faced no one can really question the
depth and thoroughness of his work
civilization and its discontents was one
of his last works and therein we can
discover a holistic interpretation of
his ideas sublimation is a psychological
term used to denote the process of
deflecting sexual instincts into acts of
higher Social valuation for example
instead of constantly chasing new
partners one can focus more on things
like Arts Reading Writing or activism in
his view all of human motivation
originates from libido libido creates
sexual impulses and to a large extent
the need for power most people are
unable to satisfy these needs and they
eventually become neurotic and even
aggressive the principle of sublimation
can influence the functioning of our
mental apparatus in such a way that it
can allow it to focus on higher Pursuits
in an attempt to stay psychologically
balanced such a shift of Consciousness
can have a tremendous impact on the way
we view the world but also on the way we
view ideas like
perfectionism although at the beginning
of the video I stated that idols could
create false equivalences of perfection
the Strategic adoption of archetypes has
always been essential to the development
of the S because they act as anchors I
really admire Sam Harris for instance
and I consider him my idol I don't need
to compare myself to him but there is a
point to be made as far as the role of
idols and archetypes is concerned by
understanding the archetypal structures
in your own psychology and in our
culture you understand how to be
autonomous you must have some values and
understand where these values come from
they don't emerge organically within you
you grow up around your parents and
peers and copy them and develop some
Independence that is empowered by the
people you admire who also got their
values from other people it is a
synergistic process where do those
values come from and what exactly are
they that's where archetypes come into
play archetypes according to Carl Yung
can Aid the integration of the ego with
the personal and Collective self they
act like a mental compass that can point
the person in the right direction
especially during dark moments however
their role should be confined to this
realm and shouldn't overwhelm the
individual with the stress of perfection
some Harris might be an idol for me but
comparing myself to his perfect Persona
is inefficacious use idols and
archetypes strategically but avoid the
mistake of worshiping and Obsession at
the end of the day we're all humans and
you never know what happens behind
closed
doors epicus is one of the three main
pillars of the stoic movement along with
Marcus orelus and Sena in his most
famous work the enerion he begins with
the following passage there are things
which are within our power and there are
things which are beyond our power within
our power are opinion aim desire
aversion and in one word whatever
Affairs are are our own beyond our power
are body property reputation office and
in one word whatever are not properly
our own Affairs I'm not familiar with as
to why he believes that body property
reputation and office are beyond our
power but it has probably to do with the
cultural beliefs of the time the essence
however Remains the Same focusing on our
own Affairs and things that are within
our power makes life easier
perfectionism is not within in our
control and that's because the notion of
what constitutes Perfection is
predicated upon a significant number of
individual opinions as I stated earlier
Bukowski wasn't perfect but he was
perfect for his fans many considered him
repulsive and a slobe does it matter the
reason we struggle with insecurity is
because we compare our behind the scenes
with everyone else's highlight real the
stoics understood that better than
anyone and that is why their teachings
strike a cord therefore the stoic
philosophy will always be the best cure
whenever one has to deal with
perfectionism there is usually a thin
line that separates reality from
delusion this line is very similar to
the one that separates Perfection from
imperfection the sheer ambiguity
involved in the way we Face certain
terms is of utmost importance when
trying to make sense of the world at the
end of the day what matters the most is
self- honesty and the fact that we
should respect our endeavors as much as
we should respect
[Music]
ourselves